jean marc bonjour alors on a vu que tous
les professionnels qui accueillent du
public doivent contrôler ce fameux pass
sanitaires c'est un travail
supplémentaires qui coûte de l'argent
car il faut plus de bras il sans doute
acheter ou louer des scanners oui alors
tous les professionnels qui accueillent
du public doivent contrôler
effectivement les patients ni terre ça
prend du temps c'est mécanique c'est un
travail supplémentaire donc ça va
forcément coûter de l'argent aux
entreprises ils font savoir il faut du
personnel il faut vous le disiez dans
bien des cas acheter du matériel ou même
le lot et il ya pas mal de matériel
aujourd'hui sur le marché je pense à des
lecteur de qr cordes par exemple ou des
who des scanners ça coûte quelques
dizaines d'euros supplémentaires par
jour alors on n'a pas d'estimations très
précise mais on sait déjà par exemple
que des grosses structures
d'organisation étaient obligés
d'investir beaucoup d'argent je pense
aux hôpitaux publics notamment et privés
qui s'auto afin de recruter et des
vigiles pour effectuer le contrôle des
passes sanitaires pour les visiteurs des
hôpitaux et même pour tous les malades
qui rentre à l'hôpital qui ont été
programmés je parle pas des urgences
parce que les urgences sont traités à
part il ya à peu près 4800 site a équipé
sa va représenter 10 mines vigiles soit
un coût global estimé par l'hôpital
public à 60 millions d'euros c'est donc
très important d'où un débat d'ailleurs
qui n'est parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de personnels qui sont anti
vaccins ou antipas sanitaires qui se
disent que cet argent aurait pu être
investi dans des équipements
supplémentaires les centres commerciaux
ont le même problème les galeries
marchandes supérieure à vingt mille
mètres carrés doivent contrôler qui les
portes d'accès ça va représenter à peu
près trente mille euros par porte
d'accès à la fois en personnel et en
matériel c'est à dire avec des automates
ou avec des bordes ils sont équipés de
scanners mais c'est déjà le cas dans les
stades le football n'est ce pas oui
absolument au paris saint germain par
exemple on s'est équipé absolument tous
les grands événements alors les sportifs
artistes artistique aussi alors il ya
les stades il ya les salles de concerts
qui sont déjà équipés de bornes qui
permettent de scanner le billet d'entrée
avec un code inca qr code sanitaire
c'est pas très compliqué techniquement à
faire et ça prend ça le probable
tellement de temps mais enfin il faut
quand même le matériel
et ça représente un coût supplémentaire
le même problème se pose dans les
grandes entreprises vous avez un
brassage d'hommes et de femmes très
important le matin le midi le soir
toutes ses entreprises notamment qui
sont installés à la défense sont en
train de s'équiper alors on parle
beaucoup des styles restaurant des
bistrots des cinémas ou les théâtres et
là c'est vrai qu'on les entend pas ce
que parce que pour eux ça bouleverse un
peu leurs habitudes les patrons n'ont
pas forcément les moyens d'embaucher
quelqu'un pour faire le contrôle alors
ils s'organisent ils s'organisent parce
qu'ils doivent respecter la loi bien sûr
ils risquent énormément de choses
notamment la fermeture administrative et
ils doivent aussi respecter leurs
clients vous avez beaucoup de clients
qui sont vaccinées ou qui veulent
prendre certaines précautions qui sont
donc attachés à la qualité sanitaire de
l'établissement et même si eux mêmes ne
risque rien donc ça va coûter cher
d'autant que s'ajoutent aussi à des des
réaménagements des espaces des masques
d'hygiène la distanciation mais les
mises de l'économie a promis de réunir
tous les professionnels pour faire un
état des lieux avoir une idée du coût
global à la fin du mois d'août et
négocié du concentration en financière
ça va rentrer sans doute dans le
continent coûte le fameux quoi qu'il en
coûte d'emmanuel macro 1 alors au delà
du coût du contrôle connaissons l'impact
de cette obligation sur l'activité alors
vous vous avez raison de faire la
distinction parce que d'un côté il ya
effectivement ce qu'il faut dépenser
pour assurer ce contrôle et puis de
l'autre côté eh bien il faut mesurer là
la conséquence de tous à l'obligation du
pas salutaire a déjà un impact négatif
sur l'activité des secteurs en contact
avec le public on sait par exemple
cinéma le cinéma n'a pas retrouvé ses
spectateurs il aura du mal parce que
deux plateformes type netflix se sont
imposés pendant les confinements la
question qu'il faut d'ailleurs se poser
pour toutes ces entreprises c'est de
savoir pourquoi des entreprises comme
les cinémas ont perdu à peu près la
moitié de leurs spectateurs est ce que
c'est à cause des obligations sanitaires
c'est un peu vrai ou alors à cause d'un
changement d'habitudes profond du
spectateur qui a été séduit par exemple
par netflix ça nécessite une réflexion
de la part des professionnels du cinéma
qui sont en train de la faire d'ailleurs
pour savoir ce qu'ils peuvent offrir de
façon à augmenter l'attractivité de leur
entreprise les restaurants sont un peu
touchés sont un peu dans la même
situation globalement mais globalement
si on va au delà de ces aménagements la
tisane adaptation l'effet sur l'ensemble
de l'économie sera quand même limité et
temporaire l'économie fonctionne
aujourd'hui à plein régime pour ça que
beaucoup d'entreprises sont adaptés aux
difficultés puis il faut pas oublier que
le pass à lithaire est appliqué pour
dépister des gens qui sont contaminés et
surtout pour inciter tout le monde à se
faire vacciner donc on peut espérer que
lorsque la majorité la population
française sur un maxi nets c'est bien
les passes sanitaire ne seront plus
nécessaires si l'état dépense beaucoup
d'argent sur ce chantier on peut même
prévoir qu'en septembre ou en octobre
par exemple les tests pcr ou antigénique
pour lesquelles vous avez bien vu on
fait la queue aujourd'hui devant les
pharmacies et qui sont obligatoires pour
apporter la preuve qu'on n'est pas sujet
porteur et bien c'était cela qui sont
gratuits seront sans doute payant à
partir d'une fin septembre début octobre
l'allemagne vient de prendre la décision
la france le fera est ce qu'on va sortir
cette information à l'issue du conseil
de sécurité d'aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est un peu prématuré mais je crois
qu'on en sortira est ce que ça veut dire
que l'activité économique ne courent
aucun risque grave d'ici la fin de
l'année
écoutez si au bout de quelques semaines
le passe à un père se limite à un
certificat de vaccination comme il en
existe pour la fièvre jaune la polio la
variole bas ça passera les prévisions
d'activités économiques sont plutôt
bonnes et le pass sanitaire contribuer à
soutenir la confiance des acteurs socio
économiques
mieux vaut un pass à lithaire qu'un
risque de confinement et un arrêt
globale de l'activité mais l'activité
économique acura court quand même un
certain nombre de risques et à des
incertitudes c'est vrai que la
visibilité est bonne il ya des
incertitudes sur sur l'évolution
sanitaire on n'est pas à l'abri regarder
ce qui se passe en martinique ou en
guadeloupe on n'est pas à l'abri d'un
nouveau variant on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une dune réticences fortes à l'égard
de la vaccination mais je dois dire pour
terminer il ya un autre risque dont on
parle pas et qui nous guette c'est le
risque de pénurie pour un certain nombre
de matériaux ou de produits en
provenance des pays émergents il ya
beaucoup d' usine qui ont fermé depuis
quelques semaines en asie pour cause de
confinement parce qu'il ya une
recrudescence de la pandémie notamment
en chine donc on manque de ciment sur
les chantiers au manque de batteries
chez les constructeurs automobiles au
manque d'électro on va sans doute
manquer de textile et vous avez beaucoup
d'industries en europe qui vont être
obligés de lever le pied un petit peu ya
un risque d'essoufflement de l'activité
en asie mais c'était soufflement va
freiner le moteur de l'europe jean marc
sylvestre merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste et éditorialiste
économique